we had one more thing we didn't talk
about oh wow what only fans oh banning
pornography okay that's it they do only
fans and then we're done they [ __ ]
themselves but do you know the whole
story
it's not can you break it down because
some people might not know okay so
everybody so that the report comes out
can i tell you what i think before you
tell the reason
i think uh because they're a billion
dollar business right i think they're
trying to sell to mainstream and get big
sponsors and they're like yeah we're
down to buy it but you gotta ditch the
nudity the porn it's like all right
that's easy and you'll buy it so i bet
they're planning to sell that's why i
think they did it or they want to go
public because like who there was
somebody else who allowed porn and they
got was it tumblr or something did it
tumbler take it tumblr did it and then
they're like no more porn and then just
shot themselves in the foot and now
they're irrelevant that's literally mark
said yeah is it is it can you see us
still because this is kind of like
intimate we're talking about only fans
it's like yeah
[Music]
can you see that yeah
that's cool yeah
maybe maybe not me so
they're banning [ __ ] basically yeah
most of these big only fans accounts
that we know from the thoughts
or like the ig thoughts i think they're
just some nudity but it's not like dicks
going in them no like you know you know
my girl who works for me cat is on there
she likes crazy money on there but she
does
[Music]
like you know a sexy picture in like uh
lingerie or something nothing crazy ever
yeah like super classy yeah we're trying
to get dove into it she crushes yeah you
need to put a thong and get on there i
think i could i think doug will do
better though
softcore
what's soft about him
he has a soft core yeah he's perfect for
you
you're perfect for soft core you're
built
i out pull up to you by three times no
you didn't go full dead hang you didn't
go dead hanging still right now how many
did you do 21. this guy can do yeah he
is he breathes out of his nose you gotta
lift like that's on him that's whatever
anyone does for me to win yeah plus one
it's just
can you be honest though because mark is
saying something you didn't exactly say
right all right no no talk to the people
you can be al did win but was dove
cheating when he sneezed and he would be
yeah yeah yeah yeah
literally that but why is he yeah he was
cheating he was just do you know that
before i joined this little uh ruckus
gang it was him that got the nose joke
so now yeah that's why i brought him
that's why i brought you on board
i don't think i'm high because of this
snooze i think he's taking all the
oxygen
right now brendan didn't pay the ac bill
big boy studio's going out of business
but uh okay so basically all the girls
are just showing tits all these ig miles
and maybe i don't even maybe if they're
showing [ __ ] i don't even know but like
if you can still see titties people are
gonna still pay correct so it's just the
people who are [ __ ] and if i want to
see [ __ ] i'm not paying five dollars
i'll go on porno a lot of people a lot
of people are though like nicole
anderson who's huge on there so that was
her way of saying hey
yeah she's huge porno star
uh she's date my buddy anyways though
you didn't bring her up but she
so you brought her up well you know so
on on youporn they take their cut like
braziers or whatever it is they take a
huge cut only fans she gets all the
money i love you
it sounds so brother yeah yeah she gets
all the money she gets all the money she
has twenty percent they take twenty
percent yeah but that's that's still
better look at her
dime piece so she she makes you know
whatever let's say 600k a month only
fans they take it away she has to go
back to [ __ ] new porn sign a deal
with uh you know reality kings gets half
her money yeah also the thing with the
only thing is you're not paying
necessarily for the sex you're paying
for the relationship and that's another
thing that's
right it's the parasocial relationship
you know that cat doesn't have to do
that herself they have these agencies
i'm aware okay it's a hustle it's an
indian call center i think they have an
indian call center set up and so that's
how you got to get guys off of only fans
is you got to just put the message in an
indian accent and then you'll be off or
but we don't want only fans go away wait
what you don't want the fan base to just
go away because it [ __ ] those
only fans to go away why
because i thought it'd be a more
salacious take
is there more salacious take than that
i will take that one
i have no attachment to all the fans i'm
sad that it's taking away the indian
call center guys that's true yeah
because all this texting they're [ __ ]
you're turning me on so much like that
thing like that's you're making me so
some indian guy he had the mexican joke
in the beginning
now
he's an immigrant dude he's not even
[ __ ] white yeah you are white but
you're an immigrant dark white yeah he's
dark white yeah
from montreal
white no no no no no no yeah you're
right you're a white fighter you're a
white walker you're whiter than canada
quakers nothing gets whiter in montreal
what what you're right you're a white
child dude white is [ __ ] you're a
white walking kid jay-z doesn't have
jay-z drake
actually we don't even need to turn on
the lights just have mark sit on the
table
listen only fans girls go keep making
your money from these guys it's only
five dollars it's the biggest it's the
best deal in the world imagine just
paying five dollars you just see the
girl that you think is the hottest girl
on the planet you just see her tits and
[ __ ] yeah like what a [ __ ]
unbelievable bargain amazing and if
you're hot enough that you know [ __ ]
ten thousand guys want to see it god
bless you
i'm okay with only fans i think it's
great i think it's fine awesome i just
think that i wonder why they're doing it
though has to be to get bought out they
they want to get ipo dude they want it
it's the i think it's the credit it's
just about sex
you know i heard i heard it's the banks
yeah because the the banks don't want to
they did the same thing with pornhub
wait they did yeah they're like clean up
your site because we don't want our
company to be tied like they don't want
that ad to the chat when i buy child
porn i use mastercard like they don't
want that [ __ ] you know what i mean well
i don't think so i don't think the issue
is you're actually touching on with the
child porn i don't think it's just
showing tits and [ __ ] i think they
can't control or they're not controlling
well enough who's subscribing to the
only fans you got a bunch of like
[ __ ] 10 year olds that are
subscribing to these like naked i don't
know what the sign up process is i would
assume there's like 21 or over i mean
they say are you 21 and then oh yeah or
something like that maybe they show your
id but you can get an id but also it
could be underage people showing [ __ ]
and tits and that's what they don't want
and the banks are like we're not
touching any of this [ __ ] if there's
like a prostitution thing apparently
there's also 30 money there's also a an
illegal country thing going on so like
some countries don't allow like sex work
like that ah and so now other countries
are like yo we can prosecute and only
fans is complicit and they're a partner
in the crime yeah if they're
facilitating the transaction and then
you were saying that something like we
think a billion dollars is a lot like we
think a billion dollars is a lot it's
all free but for a bank they're like
that's adorable sweetheart correct
there's four of us that oh my god yeah
it feels inappropriate to talk about
this with this looks like
i'm sorry for what i said i'm sorry for
what i said earlier yeah i think we have
all the individuals
keep that same energy
this poor woman doesn't have a visa but
i don't
[Applause]